I was staying at the Hilton Universal
Hilton and uh taking the elevator
upstairs walking back to the room and as
I'm walking to the room I can hear the
phone ringing inside the hotel room and
I like open the key and I run it and I
answered the phone and it's my managers
like you got it
and that was it that's why I got the
part wow
I always ask this question yeah Ryan
knows it but this is your first TV show
this is you're one of the leads did they
pay you a lot no comparatively speaking
what what did someone back in
1999 it was 99 get paid to be a an actor
of your caliber of your staff which was
none which was none exactly zero I'm
gonna guess
you probably got paid
twenty five thousand dollars
[Music]
wow 15
000. look it's lower than that and let
do you really wanna yeah that's from the
past sure they gave me 10 grand 10 grand
an episode
but I was only guaranteed 7 out of
Thirteen I wound up being in all of them
uh and that was because Scott sassa the
then Network president saw a script that
the I was not in and I don't know if he
had it if he liked me as an actor if he
liked what he saw what I did or whatever
but I remember getting that script at
home looking through it and going oh
Neil's not in this one
um and I remember telling my mother she
was like oh that's fine you have a week
off I was like Mom if I'm not in it I
don't get paid
oh and I just thought okay fine I got a
week off and then like two days later
they sent me a new draft and I was in it
and I found out Scott sassa the
president of NBC said all the Geeks are
in it every episode
who do you think got paid the most oh
got to have been Linda or Siegel or
Franco one of those three got paid so
substantly more yeah they were they were
probably making closer to to 20 to 25 or
whatever right right because they some
of them had real credits
um were you were you friend friendly or
just would you are you still friendly
with who would you say are your closest
friends out of that group now I'm
definitely closest with John he and I
have always been tight John Daly John
Daly um because you guys were best
friends on the show yeah yeah
um and and he was three he's like three
years younger than I am so you know
Martin and I and and Seth were all 17
John's 14. this was tough that's a
that's a sizable age difference at that
age uh but then the show ended and like
I just liked John so so John was the
only one you really hung out with
immediately after the show he's the only
one I saw regularly socially yeah were
there any crushes or any love making or
anything behind the scenes that were
going on there were plenty of crushes uh
did you have a crush oh everybody we all
had crushes but did anybody hook up yes
I mean I famously I think oh she's Linda
and Jason right right right of course
that's because the movie uh right uh
Forgetting Sarah Sarah Marshall right uh
and uh but no I never had any dalliances
with any of this were they broken up by
the way uh did they break up during the
Run show no no they got together
together but it worked really hard to
keep it down yeah right uh and they did
like it wasn't until long after the show
was over they were like hey did you know
and something like I knew yeah the [ __ ]
you did
um
foreign